la relación tensa que tomó otro gélido
giro el miércoles rusia convocó al
embajador de eeuu anatoli antónov de
vuelta a moscú tras las declaraciones
del presidente estadounidense joe biden
sobre su homólogo ruso vladimir putin
que es un asesino
así que qué precio debe pagar expresión
que va a pagar lo verás frontur ver los
comentarios de baile han hechos en una
entrevista con el vice news se
produjeron a raíz de un informe
desclasificado de la inteligencia de
eeuu que determinó que putin autorizó
influencias para ayudar a donald trump
en las elecciones presidenciales del
pasado noviembre
moscú ha rechazado las conclusiones por
considerarlas infundadas rusia no tiene
nada que ver con ninguna campaña contra
ningún candidato
en este sentido decimos que este informe
es erróneo no tiene absolutamente ningún
fundamento ni ninguna prueba sin embargo
el kremlin subrayó su deseo de evitar un
deterioro irreversible de las relaciones
por su parte las críticas de la
administración trump a rusia marcan un
claro alejamiento de la firma de
posición de choam para decir algo
negativo del presidente ruso
nuestra relación se verá diferente será
diferente alzaremos la voz en aquellos
temas que nos conciernen ser niños rusos
tendrán que rendir cuentas por las
acciones que han tomado en los últimos
comentarios de biden añaden
especulaciones sobre si washington
impondrá nuevas sanciones a moscú pronto
esto después de imponerlas a cuatro
altos funcionarios rusos por el
envenenamiento y posterior
encarcelamiento del crítico opositor
alexéi navalni